oh man I've I've come back
just uh just a quick just when I uh
what's the what am i hey what is going
on YouTube my name is David and I'm here
to say I [ __ ] your mom and yeah that's
about it alright you look good today you
look [ __ ] fantastic you know that
weird little thing in your eye yeah it's
gone I swear God but welcome back to the
channel and you guys know every now and
then I take mental breaks from what I'm
doing but I'm back baby because I'm here
to give you what you want tell me what
you want
so ask and ye shall receive it oh [ __ ]
so let's get right into it recently a
subscriber asked David I had been
dealing with low self-esteem for quite a
while and I've been feeling this recent
wave of positivity online when it comes
to loving yourself and I'm really trying
to follow I still don't know how to love
myself even though I've been trying I
don't feel it's pretty smart or as
creative and sometimes it's hard to see
what I got going on for myself you seem
to always be happy and love yourself
despite everything so how do you do it
well hold on we're winding that back
real quick you seem to always be happy
and love yourself despite everything so
how do you do it before we get into the
advice first of all what what you mean
despite everything [ __ ] despite the
fact that you look like a reject kpop
star going through hard times I know I'm
not like YouTube but you hadn't like I'm
the blueprint for ugly and [ __ ] defect
anyways let's just break down a few
things that you're saying now personally
for me I feel is already problematic
just right off the jump listen I know
about that recent wave of positivity
that everybody's on they're like trying
to give inspirational quotes through
tweets and Instagram 24/7 hey guys my
name is Emily and I just wake up with my
tae latte every morning and life is
sunshine yeah or the guy version of that
would be wake up and tell yourself you
wanted Sun if you ain't gettin it then
you up open mouths get fed closed mouth
don't get fed [ __ ] ass [ __ ] and you
don't deserve nothing if you ain't
getting out there and grinding your sand
this is my daddy left me when I was
super young and I'm fine right off the
bat I really don't pay attention to a
lot of that pseudo happy [ __ ] in my
opinion a lot of people have to write
that they're happy and they're
succeeding all the time because just
like you they want to believe in all
this [ __ ] that they're saying
because they feel that if they say it
more that they'll feel it more but in
reality they're probably some of the
most miserable [ __ ] people on earth
for me I know when people are happy not
based on what they post or say it's a
feeling that you get when you're around
them you could sense that joy listen I
love myself I'm happy is there a
transformer going through Glendale all
the time like what what are you shipping
at like 3:00 p.m. [ __ ] how do you minute
but it's not like that all the time and
sometimes what I'm down it's a struggle
we're all guilty of this I do this [ __ ]
sometimes too when I used to do a lot
when I was younger I used to think that
if I gave advice to people on how to be
happy and what ways they can be happy
and if they believe in that [ __ ]
that I would believe it too but it never
worked out that way that's why you have
[ __ ] nine year olds on Twitter giving
you financial and relationship advice
you were just a sperm a few years ago
you feed his [ __ ] go suck on a titty
and develop a full brain first before
you tell me what to do with my life
embryo boy listen I love myself I am
happy straight up if social media or how
other people are conducting their lives
on a platform or they can lie about how
they feel and who they are as a basis
for you to figure out what makes you
happy
you're kind of [ __ ] up that sounds
ridiculous doesn't it you are trying to
find what makes you happy by finding out
what makes somebody else happy and when
you say it out loud
it sounds a little crazy you fed into
this [ __ ] or somebody convinced you
that every day you gonna feel yourself
and you gonna feel like you the [ __ ] but
that's not the case there are days where
you work winton hate yourself you're
human so am i and emotions are complex
you think we were designed to feel a
singular emotion every day 24/7 I
don't think that's how it is humans are
complex because emotions are complex if
you were supposed to be happy every day
of your life then what the [ __ ] are all
the other emotions for do you see what
I'm saying I know this sounds so simple
but you're not supposed to be happy all
the time like when's the last time you
saw a decent human being happy as [ __ ]
at a Funeral I would like to mourn the
death of my father who was hit by a
semi-truck
she was this is kind of a loaded
question it almost feels like you want
me to give you this blueprint to
happiness that if you follow these
instructions or even if you follow the
blueprint you will figure out what makes
you happy but I can't figure that out
for you it's not really how it works I
know what makes me happy I know what
makes me tick because I took the time to
figure that out for me it's humor but
straight up my formula may not be the
solution to your equation and it's your
job to figure that out whatever I've
said or sometimes when I see [ __ ] up
situations I always turn the humor
because it's a way to twist and turn a
lot of tragedy into positivity which is
something that I grew up with allotted I
grow up with a lot of stuff I grew up
really poor you know I got my ass beat
growing up I got jobs like you know all
these crazy sad stories but with humor
comedy and even doing stand-up I was
allowed to turn this misery into joy in
when I made other people laugh it made
me laugh and there was a coping
mechanism for me that really changed my
perspective on on life in general and I
always tend to look at the glass
half-full because of it there will be
days when you look at yourself you're
not gonna like the way that you look
you're not gonna like the way that your
clothes are fitting you're not gonna
like the way that your voice sounds
you're not going to even like the way
people [ __ ] look at you but all that
[ __ ] passes your situation isn't unique
everybody goes to that shape I go to
that [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time my last
bit of advice is just to reiterate what
I was talking about before stop defining
your happiness based on what other
people put out because that's just a
dead end trust me my friends I've been
down that road and it [ __ ] sucks
I wasn't once a boy in seventh grade
watching porn with these dudes with huge
dicks and I was like man when I grow up
I'm gonna get a big ol dick like that
and that happened I was a 20 year old
man wondering why my addicted and looked
like a third arm
is everybody's dick supposed to be nine
feet long and my penis is pine all right
it's it's quite quite above-average I'll
tell you that I'll show you if you have
to turn off Twitter if you have to turn
off Instagram for a little bit do it
because you might need that mental break
and your mental health is just as
important as your physical health so
give that a go try it out and really
find what makes you happy my friends
that good cool
see y'all next time well what is going
on you too thank you for tuning in
remember if you have questions and
comments and you want me to dress tough
maybe I might address it in the podcast
maybe I might address it into these
individual videos but leave it in the
comments below or you can message me at
the genius brain podcast email that you
will see in the link in the description
box below write questions be into active
how give give this a person advice if
you feel like you know the answers right
let's be interactive on the space I will
be here more often doing these videos
and it really depends on what you guys
send me so if there's articles if
there's anything else let's let's get it
baby
LGI let's get it let's go yeah I
remember genius brain podcast every
Thursday and Sundays right in those
comments be interactive and remember
we're on every single audio platform
Thursday's as Sundays I will see you
then and of course you'll get these
videos too just make sure that you hit
that notification button and get ready
to watch these videos baby